we going to have a nice household of the
Mahomes household and Brittany will have
her hands full for sure Kansas City
Chiefs quarterback Patrick Mahomes team
just got bigger because he and wife
Brittany just welcomed a baby boy with a
winning name whenever you're home and
you're you're with your daughter and my
son when he when he gets here you have
to be dad you have to be energized ready
to play the couple posted this sweet
photo of their newborn in a brown and
white tie-dyed onesie laying on top of a
blanket with Mahomes printed over it his
full name Patrick bronze Lavon Mahomes
III the name Patrick an obvious homage
to his dad and Grandpa little bronze was
born Monday November 28th at seven
pounds eight ounces and in case your
eyes missed it baby boys already blinged
out with a sparkling chain that says his
name
Patrick and Brittany are already proud
parents to one-year-old daughter
Sterling Skye who they welcomed in
February 2021. Sterling has a ton of
energy and she loves to run around and
and do everything and I mean it makes
you happy just to be around someone that
just enjoys every single day like that
fast forward to May 2022 and the couple
announced their family was expanding
just two months after they tied the knot
in Hawaii I'm extremely excited all
gender reveal is coming up soon so
hopefully we get we get we get a boy but
I love uh him or her either either way
yeah and when the gender reveal finally
happened Patrick exploded with happiness
I think it's a girl that's my guess
we are having a boy we are having a boy
guaranteed boy
This Magic Moment
and so new what's lacking the other
until I congrats to the family of four
and then it happened
[Music]